how's it goin breasts my name's Fiona
back and welcome to beyond two souls
it's late I just got everything set up
and I'm so excited to play this one I've
been waiting for it for a long time
every once in a while on this channel we
do story dream driven games and it's
usually very well received from you bros
The Last of Us was amazing The Walking
Dead was amazing and it's just like a
daily routine that would go from here so
I hope you will jump on this journey
with me and I know it's gonna be a great
one I promise you that so enough
chitchat
let's just play I was born with a
strange gift the ability to see what no
human being has ever seen before it's
all mixed up in my head
the images the sounds the smell the
graphics they put things in order right
up to this moment
remember who i am if i had to say how it
all began
she's talking about her haircut am i
just a start here so Ellen Page his in
two games this year but what if I'd
found you by the side of the road in the
middle of nowhere was there an accident
did someone try to hurt you looks fine
how about a name someone I could contact
you must have family friends someone who
could tell me who you are
hey love interest number one no talk
much do you
well if you don't help me I can't help
you come on
why is Elly so uptight no she was way
better when she wasn't a teenager got a
scar
so recent oh oh but yes no idea what the
play tell them to wait until I get there
is that who I think it is get back to
them immediately you hear me you've got
to stop them
goddamn fools you're gonna kill everyone
ally don't kill everyone
just cuz Joel kill everyone doesn't mean
you can do it oh she's fine I don't
really like one movie that's sorry when
games start off as movies I kind of want
to play right away I know heavy rain
started right away but hey let's just
it's through our I gotta be patient
earlier
I'm not wearing any pants by the way
where's she that lets fly where is she
it's like guy in the background
for fine Oh what's his name again Africa
hi
oh damn got girl in berserk why did he
survive though Joey what have you done
not a scratch - that's weird
[Music]
I guess he was in the afternoon
all right well it's interesting so far
what is this experiment prologue broken
just like that that else get later
I think that's what it's called so they
monitor her yeah that's all right
that's sweater sweet sweaters only job
good I'm glad yeah I hate to bother you
when you play in its time
[ __ ] you I like your little dresses now
get to play I get to do stuff alright
let me see her ah nailed it genius pills
I can play with Barbies damn that horse
damn I lived the perfect life
oh what's the thing is that things I can
interact with I can't play with but what
about this I was sorry I just want check
out a little things it's fun you know
what do we got a room black from heavy
rain that had like the weird cartoon or
whatever oh that's interesting
they're walking is still awkward as hell
that teddy is similar to awesome teddy I
have ever seen alright let's go with the
man see what he wants alright
Nathan's waiting for us there's Nathan
why am i making out with the door handle
sassy even at a young age
alright there we go it's pretty
interesting so far can early to tell
what's going on though all we know now
hey you look pretty today I'm stopping
so I'm at a hospital look around that
guy looks interesting should we checking
him out let's let's see what's that
what's what hi
iodine you don't have a watch
you're not fooling anyone all right I
get it not waste time
Jodi how's your day been so far oh cool
[Music]
am I gonna do tests no I don't what is
that okay I'm gonna put this on now I
look scary it's just like a car homeless
look every princess needs his crown
don't worry I think she's gonna be fine
I'm right next door if you need me okay
okay they look like one of those aliens
from a BP
hey Jody can you hear me shrug or yes
yes I don't want to be difficult okay
hey kids already know I don't and she
has the same cards as you and we're
gonna get her to choose one and see if
you can tell us which one she chose oh
cool you think okay sure good all right
let's go for it
first card how am I supposed to know
though so I can move and look whoa whoa
Dutch camera okay all right let's sneak
peek at her sorry the card it is okay
and now I exit and she was I do believe
she was does plutt just kidding sorry
next door
[Music]
genius peered strikes again I do the
same thing
well I'm sorry but the the way to
control this is so funky
alright there's that we got it easy
peasy lemon piss PPC go again okay fine
geez I can do this all day the drunk cam
all right what are you looking at what
are you looking at you're trying to
trick me you're trying to trick me God
okay the bacon all right she has the
bacon of course that cow Jody let's try
something else
oh all right this should be cool
denne denne denne denne ten ten ten ten
ten ten ten Ted how do i how do I do it
I hold that one uh-huh and then her top
I am let's do that on her stop pants
stop okay I hold that thing oh no don't
do it le bye all right anything else are
we done
let's do it on the papers ha ha ha yeah
that's right I'm your worst nightmare
the water
ha-doo-ken let's do it on her where's
her car no I did check Hey ah let's do
it on her know what else the tables left
yes the cameras ain't no stopping when
Peter pot popping oh no no no it ain't
over till I say it's you pick the bacon
who lock the door anyway come down tap I
[Music]
think I broke pretty much everything you
can they break her now please come on
okay
[Music]
on the kids
[Music]
oh I could have stopped whenever I
wanted yeah realize oh no oh poor girl I
thought she was evil I didn't get it oh
[Music]
now it now it will never be over
so she can't control it
interesting they didn't tell me I could
quit I didn't realize I know look at me
like that I know what you're thinking
and I like it you dirty dirty somebody
tell me let's play a little more it's
only been a little while where are we
now
oh okay whatever what are we doing here
let's be let's be shy I feel like
everyone's doing us
that's not just a feeling everyone is
looking at us I dress
mistress sex dress is perfect you look
great
most important thing act natural okay
speaks to you just smile I didn't know
yet a sense of humor Brian I'm delighted
you could attend
always a pleasure she got man what's the
plan B I would like you to meet my
assistant Elizabeth I was unaware that
American diplomacy was undertaken with
such disarming charm pleasure is mine
Elizabeth gentlemen I give you back your
host we'll talk later
until then right I'm sure those guys are
really nice the whole time you're
imagining my head on a stick
you found you Charlie I should be
flattered I'm gonna shake some hands
blend in and plant some more quietly you
know you have to do
ambassador a sight for sore eyes
wait we need to find a quiet place I
love the way she walks it looks really
she's way too skinny though but I okay a
quiet place okay the game just realized
I'm stupid and told me to go here I was
actually about to go there come on
okay everyone it's girls I can't read I
hope so
50/50 right hey girls let's try to blend
in what are we doing here I love I love
that about these games those tiny tiny
details it doesn't really matter but
it's like okay it's cool it's cool don't
get me wrong it's cool okay now we can
get a bit that is one fancy as totally
die him oh god I thought she was gonna
poop for a second okay what do we got
Ellie get your [ __ ] together get it
right I don't know you ready there's a
large painting of one of the rooms
upstairs behind it is a safe the
documents were looking for her inside
but there are guards and cameras so you
have to be careful you got it
what okay let's go Oh
move up okay cool
it's like hell when you're too far away
move down okay
that's good where are we like it looks
like we're going where I wish I knew
let's try here okay cool and now he can
sneak in safe we should be safe okay
good so whoa oh [ __ ]
huh see you can't squeeze too hard stop
stop
blood goes in your brain oh I can't stop
no I can't
what is wrong with me okay what's next
on the list the guards what am I doing
here
no way be careful you know you can't
touch other people in your control
lessons I can't touch other people when
i controlling someone okay
hi it's finite it's gotta be a switch
somewhere to move the painting find it I
did it okay
geez calm down it's gonna be fine
painting trying to know okay let's check
these drawers there we go No
ah bingo
[Music]
why would you keep a hit in place if
you're gonna keep the sick act nothing
Oh perfect no we need someone else it's
not working get the guard out of here
and open the safe okay just calm down
it's gonna be okay
listen why thing can happen nosebleed
okay who's Aidan yeah I I don't know how
I do this but much longer okay
I'm not moving
Oh Shay uh r1 okay okay easy
r1 circle
oh dude dude I did not need to see that
come on how do we not have the new not
girls don't poop come out to there at
once
[Music]
[Music]
she's working with us right
I hope so sorry can't do anything - oh I
got a click okay oh no oh she seems fine
now okay it's a poker face okay how
about we wash our face there we go all
right golden train
rich paper
[Music]
all right let's get out here
mission completed right
right what a lame party yeah he's like
I'm never inviting girls again okay that
is cool well I'm interested so far I
think I will leave it there for the
first episode I really appreciate if you
personally would like to hate this
series off I'm gonna keep these daily
and I hope you boys will join me I'll
try to keep them 30 minutes or something
more if you both want me just let me
know and I'll see you in the next one
stay awesome race love you
[Music]